hi Bob yo what's up do you guys know
each other Natan Bob I've open Foreman
Zanies and astral okay and then yeah hi
Bob it's good to see pal I love you I
love you their hands the things it's
very popular right now I know I don't
know if you've been reading the news oh
my god yeah well do you know a lot you
probably know a lot about masturbation
why don't you do I was single in between
every relationship that I had to put
down so yeah but you still jerk off when
you're in a relationship
I'll jerk off with my feet if I could
would you like a girl jerk you off with
her feet no but I bet in two feet
whenever I've seen that whenever I've
seen people do foot stuff I'm like what
so did you Bob do you know a lot you
know like do you know Harvey I'm you
talking about the sexual stuff do you
know him at all I'm sure you know
everybody in Hollywood when I started I
was brought up I was on a comedy show
college tour and 22 years old I was in
Buffalo New York and Harvey Weinstein
booked me into a club and Brad grey who
became my best friend and my manager and
then ran paramount and then we just lost
him this year pretty sad
let me spring the show wait that's fine
here well yesterday I know Harvey just
leaves down a sea of Subway the holes
and and and he managed me Harvey and
Brad managed me I signed with them in
Buffalo I didn't know her I knew Brad
grey before I did that but I didn't know
Harvey you actually managed people he
did for a while and then then they split
and then I stayed with Brad so is it
difficult to watch a guy who you have a
personal relationship with it's robbery
no that's not difficult believe me I've
done it yes you have I oh my I sent him
a sexual message and I meant for a woman
yes humiliating and you were you always
honored me too by coming to him and you
was just sitting it I don't know what
restaurant I was oh I was at bars a
trolley I remember exactly what I was
drinking now but then you sent me the
text and it said hey can you help out a
dude no can I get a hand it was a code I
would use it this girl she was a really
[ __ ] sexy and she would come over in
the Bob oh you [ __ ] Ludovic know for
a combination of Anthony Weiner and
Walter Matthau
but she would uh you know I she would
just we had a dirty relationship and she
was still in my favor but I sent him it
was meant for him II like it's a get
back off thank God
so you just just sent in the key words
to him anyway you know what I'm talking
about
who do you think is it Saget but it was
I'm so sorry bro I thought you were this
girl that I know that jerks me oh yeah
that's a hard for you to see what's
happening to him or did you have it did
you end it with a good relationship with
him and now you're watching I used to
like ran into him last time I saw him
was at the Golden Globes and that was
just I just knew him you know I didn't
know I had no idea I mean I knew that he
did what he did it as a power-hungry
guy that show that when movies were
about but and you never shocked when you
find out a producer does something but
this is a shocking time this is just
bizarre and it's upsetting his [ __ ] yeah
I I'm not I'm not enjoying it are you no
I mean yeah no I was like I am I like it
watch a big guys fall yeah yeah I don't
know it's kind of great it's crazy it's
always when you hear stuff and
everything goes like down like this
you're like that's pretty nuts man like
what's gonna have because there's got to
be good people that are like scrambling
that are like oh my god like if you're
not enjoying it do you think it's a good
thing like I think it's a good thing
that this is happening I actually had
that same theory because I'm always
trying to be up with people that somehow
all this [ __ ] that were in all this
negative
craziness will teach us not to do it
again that we're not well it'll be more
careful there's a lot of boy there's a
lot more one way producer flights to
Europe right now well the problem is if
people that you've been hearing rumors
about for a long time to if there's
certain directors and stuff not hey this
guy [ __ ] a lot of girls but like hey I
hear that guy was [ __ ] fumbling with
kids like we've heard rumors about
people that yeah that is a way right and
the other thing is if you're knocking on
the door in someone's you know room and
you make a plan that's different you
know we're gonna do something feisty but
if you're using your dick and you're
hitting it you know hitting the knob and
then you go in and then you're kind of
if you're whacking a plant I mean what
do what is that mean sure he came in a
plant Harvey do you know what is
I mean you're actually its fertilization
it's probably good for them you've never
jerked off in a plant no I try not Venus
flytrap I had to see more suck my dick
from below me see more but no I don't I
don't want to [ __ ] plants I mean am i
new special not to mention it at all - I
know that's it I didn't know about it
tell me about well it's a-you know about
everything you you you look at you the
king of everything right here with your
hand now you're failing in fast no
you're not thank you Bob no you're doing
great everybody knows it 60 you'd be
surprised how accurate Jim thank you Sam
very much so zero to 60 is it on Netflix
it is not okay it's the first time
anything's been released this way which
Harvey also said but it's a new model
which I dated once but now I got a good
woman I'll tell you about her in a
minute but this 0 to 60 thing is out now
on everything it's on of course iTunes
in in vinyl and it's not an Amazon but
it's on every single cable system in the
world
Wow at the same time on damn it right
it's the first time comedy dynamics it
I'm the first person that's ever had
this happen it's like another model
where you you get to be a you know you
get to co-own or whatever the hell it is
yeah but the main thing is it gets to be
seen by everybody so it's on Spectrum
dish you know whatever you got speculum
if you if you got the cold thing the
doctor puts in it Sun boogers it's on
you know hymens but but in reality it's
on DirecTV and Google Play I mean it's
literally it's a way that a comedian
that they can take it and then if they
luck out and everybody says okay we'll
let it go everywhere which is really
weird cuz you got a lot of competition
yeah so it would be on the thing you're
gonna go you're gonna watch Wonder Woman
and jerk off for the ninth time or you
want to watch zero to sixty and talk
here about Bob and jerk-off it's really
funny by the way
oh thanks man we had fun in Nashville we
did and I was single then wasn't I yeah
I ain't no more all right
last time I was there I had a telling
Nathan he doesn't have a chance exactly
yeah he can bust my hymen tell eaiser is
your fiancee Union congratulations yeah
thanks did you meet her ever I don't
think I did please don't touch her
and I wouldn't but you're clean you're
kind of clean you're like not wait a
second he does everything but he watches
himself he does well you watch your
hands I'm what I've watched you wash
your hands
yeah in urine and semen and I think it
offends me watch my throat to semen is
not just a food group anymore ever see
Caligula is a great see if she's laying
there and all these soldiers are jerking
off to her but that's how you learned it
was good for your skin and yeah calm is
good for your skin that's that you know
no one's gonna argue with you so you are
going down fast aren't you no I'm just
saying I thought Caligula in that
theater and I was actually in a theater
in Detroit and this guy he was a partner
with Marc really of the comedy castle
back in the day it's like 35 years ago I
guess and it's gore Vidal I believed it
was yeah Bob Guccione was a producer I
think yes penthouse it had a real
[ __ ] in it and it was in a regular
theater with an x-rated movie and I
remember sitting with a guy who and this
is sad as [ __ ] it's weird and Dame was
Dan Trent and he passed away from cancer
and he was like dying while watching
Caligula but it was his dream to go see
Caligula with me and I got nothing to do
him in Detroit work in the club sounds
like a nice afternoon simply got it's
Diane watching Caligula and Malcolm
McDowell was the star and it's like John
Gielgud is in it every Bolano tool a lot
of guys at one of the sea people I
wouldn't Mirren Helen Mirren was in it
she was very good but those people had a
separate movie going on right they
weren't you know the other movie where
people are you know spewing all over
each other but there's at one point
Dan's uh he says I can't watch the movie
my scalp won't stop bleeding and they I
said this is a sad day and he said I had
this happen at fiddler on the roof when
I went to go see I said well that
happens to all non-jews you gotta wear a
yarmulke
it's a yarmulke it's a good you know
it's a drip pan did you really get your
your the science of the skin from
Caligula me I just that's where I
learned that that happens 1980 I think
so I mean I don't think it's true I
don't think you've formed that up
in that come is good for your skin no I
asked why they would somebody told me
that was why they do that because it
does it's good for your skin have you
found that to be true my stomach looks
like a porn you you pull out and shoot
all over each other and in life that's
not always the case now of course people
do use the internal route yes that's
good I think so yeah why are you looking
right into my eyes well I'm saying
what's there no blankness dead so how
long have you been engaged for it's been
three weeks
really yeah we were watching stranger
things we were up in Northern California
I turned it off went to the safe took
out the ring that I'd had for four days
she had no clue at all were you did you
were you waiting for just a moment when
I wasn't I wanted us to go through this
thing where we had this amazing time
together
and and I guess in a way I just wanted
to be sure the timing was right and
everything and it was just one of the
nicest it's like I was married 22 years
ago and I've had like six girlfriends
that I put down you know they're in the
backyard and you know I put a funnel in
how did you ask her what you said her I
said to her I know you hate Jews but no
[Laughter]
from Chicago so she's got a family
that's connected so I can't mess this up
no but I I just asked her romantically I
just got on the knee and that's very you
know of course that's very controversial
these days there's no flag in the room
so that's fine and she was say I don't
want to mix politics and proposals I
don't why he actually said why'd you
turn off stranger things did you say
would you marry me
you were serious I did I didn't say it
right I said I don't mind kid because I
was gonna say I want you to spend the
rest of my life with me but she's half
my age plus seven which is cool that's
very very nation of is how you do it
that that was our logic Mohammed said
half of bands age 1/2 a man's age plus 7
is the proper really yes my mama said I
feel so happily grouped in and learn and
acts
double X but what was interesting is she
the way I put it was I want to spend
whatever time I have left with you know
but it was not not the way to put it
that she went what
and then I repeated it and then we were
on the phone I had already asked my
daughters after your daughter's said is
this cool
I do you have a woman do you uh yeah
married have a five year old daughter
that's cool you married your five year
old daughter
yeah or not on board with it but you
know she's my half my age but you say
you don't do nothing with her or nothing
is taking a movie with my daughter yeah
I'm gonna do like whatever you would do
with the daughter like in reading the
paper it's pretty yeah that's true right
now as normal people I'm a normal rate
I raised my raise our daughter you know
you don't rear your daughter now did not
you don't think you're out in the woods
no stuff no and you love her a lot I
love her a lot
yes yeah I got three of them and they're
old now they're 90 and do you got kids
are you gonna plant in his house yeah
are you have more kids do you think no I
don't think so I asked my dick and he
just went yes your accountant he said
don't it's like we have something where
we're both in really NSYNC I haven't had
this in my life really I have when I was
younger I mean I got married at 26 and
so how old are you now got 38 I got
married at 26 yeah that's good 38 and
that's a good amount of time so you kind
of usually the 7-year itch is over right
yeah yeah I've been my life since I was
21 so like sorry comedy no no no just
yeah just doing that no no I mean I did
eventually get her pressure yeah yeah I
was a long time for the kids yeah you
keep it in somebody for 12 years how did
you surprise her like to get a ring you
had a size the finger Wow do you guys
talk about it I stole whatever rings but
it was the wrong finger so I had to have
it
I had to have her finger implanted no I
had to have the ring decides there's a
toe ring tell her did you take a ring
shopping for how do you know I went and
got the ring and got the one that you a
year ago we had a conversation which
comes up if you're you know being
romanced your bed right after sex you
google what's your favorite ring you
know if your life's going good so I knew
the kind of stones she likes so okay so
basically you do that kind of like hey
maybe someday what do you like and then
when X might have done the road away
into the cloud for a while so somebody
from Apple could have married her then
or steal my act for my new special
zero-to-sixty
did she cry when you asked her uh I did
no she didn't cry she did cry and I
don't know if it was that a joy like
finish strategy things yeah what
happened so funny last night I was
littered with it with her and my
daughters and she was pissed that we
haven't finished it whatever now the
excitement is is off we got three more
to go
is that sure have you not watched the
game zone I can't talk about it oh I
thought you were to do us no it's gonna
say what else were you watching know
when you probably we want to watch it
but I've been so busy to impress I do it
not impress but doing press special yeah
and that I have we have at that time and
we're literally dying to watch it so I
think I'm gonna charge up that old iPad
and get the double ear phone thing and
on the flight back that's romantic
I think yeah really but then I realized
we're in those seats that aren't next to
each other they are but you those
compartments sure because we're on
Murder on the Orient Express we're gonna
be traveling in trains yeah but yeah so
we we can't wait to see it I don't know
well it's like one of the best shows and
season two is better than season one
it's so good I mean I met those kids too
i I was on Chelsea show and the kids
were there and they were excited to meet
me which was I was like what do you
think that now cuz we were tremendous on
the show and I kind of I don't know him
obviously but like now that when I see
them in magazines and on TV and stuff
and it wasn't after
season but after this season it seems
like now they're being like sexualized
and stylized and turned into these
little mini adults which they've gotten
older and I saw them doing you know like
the attempts on James Corden they were
doing all these songs together and they
choreographed and they're showbiz and
map a little bit yeah well look I I'm
the guy that was a dad on full house
yeah you're yeah and I'm still we're
doing it are to keep you up Jim okay
always watch the whatever this is
Facebook live or out via our we do this
and it's always this angle I mean that
makes me look like I've got five months
to live
you look great it's just wishful not
from this angle the shoes means a
brooder can you there's a camera too
yeah but I don't trust that one all of
them should take every camera over there
well you have a great little presence
this way you look terrific you only know
that because you held my head down she
was how can you give a guy a hand yeah I
don't know you know if you're a kid and
you're acting and you choose to do it
it's a real weird line you can't figure
out is this what you know I worked with
mary-kate & Ashley there were nine
months old they don't grow up at nine
money and go I want to be an actor you
know and I just saw good job of treating
them like kids the entire time they were
kids and of that show they were
portrayed I love them yeah I had it with
Ashley last night with my daughters and
my fiance that was my stutter for the
day my mom I fancy and you know and I
love and the shows back that fuller
house Netflix brought it back it's like
a yeah giant can new ones come out in
December but they won't do it the twins
won't do now they don't want to act then
what they do what they do their clothing
line right yeah they do and they just
don't want to act and it just didn't
feel right and it's like people should
be able to do what they want to do like
if you wanted to do this show without
Sam what no it couldn't happen no it
never were know what this place has
never ever switched jobs nobody's ever
Jenna you can't just change the house
and keep going can't friendships can't
break up over this yeah yeah it doesn't
happen in showbiz where you don't really
talk to someone that was your best
friend for 15 years anymore you know
it's amazing they actually have a place
in here where they make Mike flags
that's how [ __ ]
it goes over it changes quickly yeah
that's how everything is you do a movie
with somebody you get real close to them
or then you have a you know I just
finished directing a movie and it's
really good it's got a lot of great
actors and then porn scenes just like
Caligula right in between just to get
the skin going good on the stomach and
because that's what you like this I
don't know man you actually look good
thank you I think it's a chair and you
made you cheer really high like
Letterman's used to be and the life
comfortable over there it is dark I
prefer a dim light that mysterious and
I'm excited that the cameras move but
all anybody's gonna look at is the front
part of it and tellest rate it to show
the neck gel one for God's you look good
for 61 not bad not great but good thanks
I'm what you're right about yeah see all
the the movies changing I mean poor
Kevin Spacey just got taken out of his
movie that he did I didn't even know
about that there's something against
everybody's not with kids like hey
that's [ __ ] it's just all bad and I
know most of these people and it's just
so [ __ ] you know Kevin yeah I mean
he's gay that wasn't a shocking no it's
just it's just if you force yourself on
somebody like I want to mount you so bad
right I understand but when I say that
yeah everything I've ever done
hey they're putting a book or I do it on
stage I don't go dry hump person's
[ __ ] butthole when they don't want it
well Jim I think North lie norden's in a
lot of trouble because he's kept a lot
of his sexual stuff private yeah on the
front of a bus here's would be it's all
not true and then that would be a
disappointment everybody's like what you
like now dude he's like missionary sex
twice a week actually said I love you a
lot what you mean like with a missionary
I mean someone trying to listen to like
a South African culture and they go yeah
oh it's at the Old Vic Theatre in London
I guess what is maybe I guess he got
accused something they're doing it's so
funny there's a lot of them like you're
like this dude I don't know how he had
time to do anything one feel like he
just
walked in was like just grabbing people
a really good actor he's good a great
mind they actually changing name is
either the old dick theater you know cuz
that rhymes a dick certainly does yeah
vapor rub that you put into young man's
back after you're done we would be able
to joke about this stuff I even did a
joke in my new special zero-to-sixty
open everywhere yes this was my show I
would say it every six seconds what's
your new special it's on your thing what
would your latest thing 0-60 no yours
yours yours
Netflix mouthful of shame yeah I watch
like half of it not because I didn't
like it because I didn't marry talking
about blowing a woman hold on I got a
gift for you there's a ring there will
be no charges pressed because you have a
consenting person doing it that you
either paying or they months what you
want yes and again I'm not saying I'm
this great guy I just might turn on to
work a certain way there's certain that
type of [ __ ] someone horrified or like
uh
I just never turned me on no and I could
how do you walk into a room and get an
erection and you've got it going and
you're ready to go
Jim has problems with the first part of
that sentence yeah exactly yeah yeah my
dick is tentative frightened yeah so
it's always that Groundhog Day
not always but you know sometimes give
pokes itani
I got nothing drop my dick oh you've
never had that with with a woman right
we're like you couldn't get an erection
I have had that thanks for bailing me
out Bob what you do for real for real
it's actually in the special right 60
yeah I get that everywhere right I get
that every all people say hashtag zero
to six to me but no you can get it at or
yeah oh you can get it on demand well
thank you I didn't realize I should play
along as a bunch of tour dates by the
way too and you know November 30th he's
going to be in Raleigh and just a whole
bunch to go to Bob Saget calm all the
dates here we got San Diego Honolulu
Morristown New Jersey I'm a little bit
Bill Maher for New Year's Eve right
you're doing that fun thing that'll be
great and then I'll be fun cuz I'll be
silly in little dirty
slightly topical and Hilda
go for it yeah it builds different and
clean it out and that's what I'm going
through
I don't know about you guys but that's
where I get my news I'm watching you
know John Oliver and Stephen Colbert and
Seth and know and Jimmy Kimmel and
that's where I get my news like I don't
watch any even watch any of your like
none of them I don't just like that I
just don't watch them they're not
talking about coming on people's backs
and stuff so maybe that turns you off no
I would like to hear that I don't
dislike them John Oliver's very funny
but I just yeah he's wonderful
yeah great no interest well what what
about the news do you watch it you are
you turning on CNN the Drudge Report or
cnn.com no I think MSNBC do you watch
anything you know if I'm looking for a
headline I'll usually go to Drudge and
then from there I'll go to CNN or MSNBC
because then you're kind of getting all
three you know but you're not getting
fox news you know watch fox news watch
it once in a while because I want to
know what everybody I want to know what
everybody is thinking and and I just
find it all it's it's lunacy we are in
the most insane time on the news
yesterday I couldn't get enough of it
thirsty Donald Shido is that right no
[ __ ] awesome he's doing this speech
in about China and he and he sounded try
to do yes he sounded like oh just dry
mouth he had to pause twice to get a
glug of water from his bottle and that's
awkward enough but the way he drinks
water is like he has to line up his lips
with the bottle before he brings the
bottle up and then there's all this
preparation and everything watch I mean
he looked like a Percy lip to fool no
this is a real stretched out screen not
what it's supposed to be we're supposed
to get a guy that gives you a public
address and talks to people at home and
takes over all the airwaves and says you
can teleprompter it's gonna be okay
we're gonna get through this
something yeah he's just thirsty the
little guy doesn't like him but Marco
Rubio is a Rocket Man for a year and
what's gonna be for us is that Kim Jong
Un's a bit of a [ __ ] doll he's been
[ __ ] around for four years I'm top
had enough of him wait you can fit in
the missile rocket man yeah yeah
snapchat sent him flying off but it's
very awkward and Marco Rubio did this he
he went for a water grab it was just
awful Marco Rubio is awkward for him
because he drank like half the bodies at
home these guys should have under the
podium like I do either an open bottle
of water because there's something about
watching him open it you just look
stupid these guys should have the glass
of water the foresight to know I'm about
to give a speech let me have some water
before I give it the scoop on the
glasses of what they should have the
staff person say we're gonna put a
bottle of water or Nate there because
they should have people working for them
because the he's the president well he
did address that he wanted some water
this is very very hard sorry how dry
disease I love I love listening to
people with a dry mouth while opening it
away from so he doesn't spill it on
himself the whole thing he look at
someone else's water does his lips
before Oh hands like a chair that's an
infant drinks water yeah like he perhaps
himself before yeah before he drink it
was way before you said Japanese many
drink Fiji water it just seems like this
thing I shouldn't put that top back on
well yeah they're like you ever go on
stage you forget to have it undone a
little bit yes it can get hard and it is
weird it's like you're be up there and
you're like this is weird to be drinking
water in front of people like just you
know we needed thirsty I think I took a
pound I don't really do it either
actually people died for see people go
through beers yeah three beers and
you're like what do you have time well
Jim Jefferies that's part of his thing I
mean he gets up and he's funny as hell
but he goes and he starts poundin yeah
for Christ your does shots yeah like
when the audience you know I feel bad
about it but they do a shot that dude
I'm working I'm yeah my brain has to
actually function to do this you haven't
been to a Bert Kreischer show when the
audience goes to do a shot he goes
alright send one up I've seen a lot of
people over the years yeah
Ron Ron wrong way around
round would be right here yeah yeah less
why was it here Rama's in he's a great
guy really really funny dude really
funny really there are a lot of funny
dude he's a comfortably funny guy like
meaning he just talks and yeah it is
funny [ __ ] yeah just if you just I you
listen to him talk about anything for
any length of time Eddie says it cuz
he's connected and he talks slow and he
tells you about it and it's uh that's I
really enjoy people that talk like that
he's a guy who should do a podcast and
doesn't because yeah interesting guy to
listen to right there's certain people
that just have that Chappelle has that
this we're yeah 7 hours you could just
do lyrical way of speaking it's just a
comfortable way of speaking anything
connected to it that maybe that's what
it is yeah it's fits fully in my newest
special zero-to-sixty
where can people get that oh god it's
everywhere I can
that's a great question Nate can they
get it on Google Play yeah I bet you
have Amazon iTunes probably not
definitely put a pen what about like
cable on-demand that's never been done
sorry not DirecTV DirecTV immediate oh
my god in the history of humanity Wow
in other countries so you're actually
bringing everyone together with this
special well the last song in it cuz I
do do four songs I was on Marc Maron's
podcast I said I do I do I said it what
you just said doo doo no sorries awesome
I did before so I do do I was I [ __ ] for
songs Marc Maron's podcast and I gotta
do some songs he goes oh god it's like
it's like I used to go see Martin Maher
when I was starting you know and he
comedy music and that's what I've
attempted to not do his thing but I
write comedy songs forever it so what I
do and so I do the 40 minutes stand-up
and I did some music the last song is
called
we got to be kind to each other but it's
an r-rated sure my version of we of the
world and you know pink don't pay your
penis green between Easter eggs things
like that right you know but but then it
has the relevance of something positive
what's behind the special is this is all
[ __ ] we're living and and we have to
get through this so what you were saying
say I'm the I disagree about rying to
plug my [ __ ] show too much is that
there is good that will come out of
right this crazy [ __ ] because there are
producers there are people in power
there are writers there are politicians
they're just famous rich people they're
just people that are dicks that you know
are [ __ ] and dicks and [ __ ] is
you know what a Jim's favorite
absolutely yeah but but but they will go
oh I don't want to get in trouble so I'm
not gonna do this now so that's like
just right a young boy being taught
don't do this but then the real truth is
eventually it actually seeps into
society because I was having a
conversation with my kids last night and
my daughters were saying you know it's
gonna hurt women getting jobs that
people are not gonna want to hire women
because women are gonna be afraid
they're gonna get fired or guys gonna I
think there's other reasons it's the
whole thing hopefully no one goes up
from my house now